tragically not everybody has a miracle
survival story this morning we mentioned
that
at least six people have died in this
storm that includes a 14 year old girl
her name was cynthia miller and jonathan
vigliotti went to leesville louisiana
to speak with her family we went to
right out the storm in our parents room
and everyone was sitting in there and
then the tree
came down it came down it landed on her
hurricane laura left a gaping hole in
the miller family's home
when a tree smashed through crushing 14
year old cynthia
they called her cindy the millers
weren't expecting a direct hit
they hadn't even been ordered to
evacuate 18-year-old nelly miller
is cindy's older sister it was scary it
was
it was dark it was terrifying there was
rain wind everywhere
it sounded huge i didn't think a tree
would come through if it hit it's like
okay we got hit
and then my parents joined yelling hey
are you guys okay and we said yeah we're
okay so i walked to try and find cindy
because she wasn't talking
and i tried to wake her up and she
wouldn't wake up and
it took me it took me a little bit to
realize
she couldn't miller family friend
richard partridge never thought this
could happen
this one we were more prepared for we
wasn't prepared for this
this was one of those you watch it on
the news
you see it happen to somebody else
nellie miller said she'll remember her
younger sister as an
excellent student with a bright future
an aspiring marine microbiologist
who even as the hurricane barreled down
was reading a book
by flashlight she was an extrovert and
she loved people
that she was going to do something big
and cynthia had dreams of leaving the
bayou for harvard and her family says
she was first in her class she was also
the first confirmed fatality at least
three other people were killed
when trees crashed into their homes tony
jonathan for us jonathan thank you very
much and gail and anthony as i send it
back to you i can say that more
fortunate families
have already been getting back to work
and we're picking up notes of recovery
the
sound and also the smell that would be
chainsaws and freshly cut wood this is a
community that rebuilt entirely
back in 2005 after rita and everyone
expects
they will do it again yeah but now i'm
still sitting here thinking about the
miller family the more details jonathan
gave us about
uh cindy miller's life yeah the more
touching it became and then you think
about craig barker who was in your story
he said i'm nobody special nobody
different
i'll bet a lot of people tony are still
just in shock today still trying to
process what is happening well and that
huge tree lying across the road just did
just
almost as you point out tony almost cut
that house in half
a game of inches tony thank you very
much our condolences to the miller
family